as a graduate of Carnegie Mellon it is a
great pleasure yes to introduce the Dean
of Carnegie Mellon's University's
College of Fine Arts Dan Martin along
with Carnegie Mellon trustee and fellow
alum a Tony nominated producer of
mothers and sons
Paula Wagner
good evening thank you it's highly
likely that we are in the only room on
earth tonight that doesn't need a
reminder about the importance of arts
education but millions of other people
surely do that's why Carnegie Mellon
University is so proud to become the
first ever higher education partner of
the Tony Awards we're thrilled to
announce the launch of a national
recognition program to honor
kindergarten through high school theatre
educators details on how to nominate a
teacher will be announced later this
fall I have the privilege of seeing
education transform the lives of
talented young people daily and then
watching those students transform the
world including my two friends here at
CMU I studied how to be an actor a
director and a producer and eventually
became all three I rehearsed my craft
with Tony winners like my friends Judith
Light and Stephen Schwartz and I'm so
honored as a trustee to represent my
alma mater here tonight thank you and if
ever there were a student who
appreciated his teachers it was me I
will never forget a teacher who said you
can thing but you show Kain act hello
mrs. Leonard Emmet's so I thought I'd
sure better learn because this is what
I'm gonna do with the rest of my life I
trained with the trainer's I sang with
the singers acted with the actors and
for a while I even taught with the
teachers Bravo so tonight please join me
in a round of applause for the teachers
in your life who inspired you to be here
tonight thank you
who are both graduates of pogi Mellon
University Matt Bomer
and Zachary Quinto Matt and I have
actually been great friends for over 15
years
as evidenced by the fact that we're
wearing matching glasses to read them
now this year marked the 100th year of
the Carnegie Mellon University School of
Drama which has produced hundreds of
Tony nominees and 31 Tony winners we're
happy to be here tonight to announce the
very first higher education partnership
between Carnegie Mellon and the Tony
Awards CMU and the Tony Awards are
co-creating the first Tony Honor for
excellence in theatre education
recognizing arts educators nationwide
you can nominate a teacher who made a
difference to receive the award at next
year's Tony telecast for more
information go to CMU edu or Tony Awards
dot-com